place
you
almost
hello folks
good morning
i'm going to be
somewhat short today because surely
you're going to hear a
helicopter landing outside the window
here
i'm supposed to be in
colorado looking at the damage with the
governor of the
that god-awful
firestorm that rolled through and then
i'm heading off to do
harry reid's
funeral
so
but this morning
i want to talk about uh
uh i think it's historic day
for our economic recovery
today's national unemployment rate fell
below four percent
to 3.9
the sharpest one-year drop in
unemployment in united states history
for the first time the unemployment rate
has been under 4
in the first year of a presidential term
in 50 years
3.9
unemployment rate
years faster than experts said we'd be
able to do it
and we have added 6.4 million new jobs
since january
of last year in one year
that's one of the most
that's the most jobs
in any calendar year by any president in
history
how
how how did that happen well the
american rescue plan got the economy
off his back and moving again
back on its feet
getting over
2200 million americans fully vaccinated
got people out of their homes and back
to work even in the face of wave after
wave of covet
we got schools open we got booster shots
we brought down the poverty rate it went
from 20 million people on unemployment
rolls a year ago to under 2 million
people on the unemployment rolls today
america is back to work
and there are more historical
accomplishments
the increase in americans joined in the
labor force was the fastest this year of
any year since 1996
and among prime age workers ages 25 to
54
their increase in labor force
participation was the biggest in 43
years
record job creation
record unemployment declines
record increases in the people in the
labor force
i would argue the biden economic plan is
working
and it's getting america back to work
back on its feet
but the record doesn't stop there
today's report also tells us
that record wage gains especially for
workers in some of america's toughest
jobs
women and men who work in the front line
jobs in restaurants hotels
travel tourism
desk clerks line cooks waitstaff bellmen
they all saw their wages at a historic
high
highest in history
their pay went up almost 16 percent this
year
far ahead of inflation which is still a
concern
overall
wage gains for all workers
who were not supervisors went up
more in 2021
than any year in four decades there's
been a lot of press coverage about
people quitting their jobs
well today's report tells you why
americans are moving up to better jobs
with better pay with better benefits
that's why they're quitting their jobs
this isn't about workers walking away
and refusing to work it's about workers
able to take a step up
to provide for themselves and their
families
this is the kind of recovery
i promised and hoped for for the
american people
where the biggest benefits go to the
people who work the hardest and are more
often left behind
the people who have been ignored before
the people who
just want a decent chance to build a
decent life for their families just
given a clear shot
for them
wages are up
job opportunities up
layoffs are down to the lowest levels in
decades
and they're more chances than ever to
get ahead
no wonder one leading economic
excuse me analyst
describe what we've accomplished in 2021
as the strongest first year economic
track record of any president in the
last 50 years
today
america is the only leading economy in
the world where the economy as a whole
is stronger than before the pandemic
now i hear republicans say today that uh
my talking about this strong record
shows that i don't understand
i don't understand a lot of people are
still suffering they say well they are
or that i'm not focused on inflation
malarkey
they want to talk down the recovery
because they voted against the
legislation that made it happen
they voted against the tax cuts for
middle-class families
they voted against the funds we needed
to reopen our schools
to keep police officers and firefighters
on the job
to lower health care premiums they voted
against the funds
we're now using to buy covet booster
shots and more anti-viral pills
i refuse to let them stand on the way of
this recovery and now my focus is on
keeping this recovery strong and durable
not withstanding republican
obstructionism
because you know i know that even as
jobs and families incomes have recovered
families are still feeling the pinch
of prices and costs
so we're
taking that on as well
and that's the and the way to do that is
not to step back from the economic
progress we've made but to build on it
i've laid out a three-part plan
to address costs families are facing
one
first part of that plan fixing the
supply chain
two
protecting consumers and promoting
competition
three
lowering kitchen table costs including
with my build back better act
first the supply chain
a couple of months ago
we heard a lot of dire warnings about
supply chain problems leading to a
crisis around the holidays
thanksgiving and christmas
we acted
we brought together business and labor
to solve the problems
the much predicted crisis didn't occur
the grinch did not steal christmas
nor any votes
look the number of containers sets in
and on docks
for more than eight days is now down by
nearly 40 percent
the number of packages delivered on time
was nearly 99
workers stayed on the job
and did the job to bring good to
consumers
we're continuing to work to speed up
every step of this process
the ports
trains trucking
my bipartisan infrastructure plan law
included significant investments in each
of these areas
and i want to thank the 19 republicans
in the senate
the 13 in the house who stepped in to
help pass it
so we didn't have to face another
filibuster and lose
a very badly needed plan
the second area
protecting american consumers
in the last few decades
in too many industries a handful of
giant companies
dominate the market
in meat processing
railroads shipping
too often they use their power to
squeeze out smaller competitors stifle
new entrepreneurs and raise the prices
reducing options for consumers
and exploiting workers to keep wages
unfairly low
you see that in your own life
just look at your grocery bill and the
cost of meat
it's not because the cattle farm is
getting rich
matter of fact it's the exact opposite
it's because fewer processors can
charge grocery stores much more money
for their ground beef for example
you've heard me say it before
capitalism without competition is in
capitalism
it's exploitation
and i'm determined to end the
exploitation
later this month i'll be meeting with my
competition council which includes key
economic leaders from across my
administration
to keep pushing for more broad action
and increase competition across our
economy because healthy competition
produces lower prices higher wages and
more dynamic and innovative economies
that makes everybody better off
third
i'm working to reduce the largest cost
burden of household budgets
costs that don't need to be such a
burden
and the biggest weapon at arsenal is my
build back better act
which will reduce what families have to
pay
for basic necessities to live a life
raise a family
from prescription drugs to health care
to child care
and more help so families can cover the
cost of raising their children and
caring for their loved ones
their older loved ones
as we've seen over and over and over
again throughout this pandemic
if people can't find affordable child
care they can't work
right now there are two million
extremely qualified women who have not
been able to return to work because they
can't find or can't afford
child care
on healthcare
we've made quality coverage through the
aca more affordable than ever before
with families saving an average of 2 400
on our annual premiums
and 4 out of 5 consumers
finding quality coverage for under ten
dollars a month
and the result
when you reduce the cost of health care
more people can afford to get it
over four million people have gained
coverage since i became president
you've heard me say it a million times
having health care
is also about peace of mind
for example
we're going to make it so nobody will
pay more than 35
a month for insulin
imagine you're a parent
and will the one of the 200 000 children
in this country have type 1 diabetes
insulin
can cost on average it's average 650
bucks a month but
cannot cost as much as a thousand
dollars a month
even though a vial
of that incident cost about 10 bucks to
manufacture
we can do all this we do without
increasing inflation
without increasing the deficit
nobody making more than four hundred
thousand dollars a year less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year will pay
a penny more in federal taxes
so we're going to keep working on these
fronts
some of them have components that are
immediate
like unsticking the supply chain
some will show their benefits over time
like investments in infrastructure
but all will help america family
america's families
it's urgent we get moving on all of it
without delay
because at this moment as a country
we face an important choice
do we take the steps to create an
economy
with strong sustainable growth higher
wages and more opportunities for all
americans or
do we settle for an economy that wasn't
working for a middle class even before
the pandemic began
an economy that delivered sluggish
growth stagnant wages limited
opportunities
i'm not an economist but i've been doing
this a long time
but here's the way to look at it
if car prices are too high
right now for two solutions
you increase the supply of cars by
making more of them
or you reduce demand for cars by making
americas poorer
that's a choice
believe it or not there's a lot of
people in the second camp
you'll hear them complain
that wages are rising too fast among
very middle-class and working-class
people
who have endured decades of stalled
incomes
their view of the economy says the only
solution to our current future
challenges
is to make the working families that are
the backbone of our country poor or keep
them in a safe state that we're in
it's a pessimistic vision
and i reject it
i reject the idea that we should somehow
punish people because they finally have
a little more breathing room
america doesn't need to settle for less
we need an economy that has the capacity
to generate more growth
more jobs and more opportunity for all
americans
that's why we're going to keep doing
everything we can to one unstick the
bottlenecks that are keeping goods from
getting to consumers
two
build better infrastructures so that we
can get parts and goods to factory
floors quicker and cheaper
three
bring more of that production back here
to the united states
to make our supply chain more secure
let's make america
let's make what we're selling america
made in america
so we're not at risk of foreign supply
chains
and shipping delays
and in doing so
get more americans working in jobs with
rising wages
i want to be clear
i'm confident the federal reserve
will act to achieve their dual goals of
full employment at stable prices and
make sure the price increases do not
become entrenched over long term
with the independence that they need
but the best way that i as president
and the congress as a legislature can
tackle high prices
is by building a more productive economy
with greater capacity to deliver for the
american people
a growing economy
where people have more opportunities
more small businesses opening
and i might add
parenthetically there's 30 percent
increase in the application for new
small businesses
and goods get to market faster
economy we don't just grow
the economic pie to make sure people who
bake the pie get a fair slice of it as
well
for too long
republicans have thrown them around
terms like pro growth
and supply-side economics
to drive an economic agenda that didn't
deliver enough growth
and supplied more wealth to those who
already were very well off
from day one my economic agenda has been
different
it's been about taking a fundamentally
new approach to our economy
one that sees the prosperity of working
families as a solution not the problem
there's never been a time i can think of
when the middle class and working class
have done well that the wealthy haven't
done very well
working families need to get a fighting
chance and by the way
the stock market
the last guy's measure of everything
is about 20 percent higher
than it was when my predecessor was
there
it has hit record after record after
record on my watch
while making things more equitable for
working class people at the same time
who created jobs
reduced unemployment raised wages
as i've always said
when working people do well everybody
benefits
i'm determined to grow the economy from
the bottom up in the middle out
because when we do
we get more growth
higher wages
more jobs and over time lower prices
but don't take my word for it just look
at the results
historical results
revolts results for working americans
economists call this
increase the productive capacity of our
economy
i call it building back better
that's what we're going to keep doing
we're going to keep building
i thank you all very much and uh
i'll get a chance to
talk to all of you on tuesday when i
am down in
georgia talking about voting rights but
thank you
[Music]
to live with president forever sir
mr president should americans prepare to
live with povid forever sir mr president
should americans prepare to live with it
forever
[Music]
here to stay uh no i don't think covet
is here to stay that having
coveted in the environment here and in
the world is probably here to stay but
covet as we're dealing with it now
is not here to stay the new normal
doesn't have to be we have so many more
tools we're developing and continuing to
develop that can contain covet and other
strains of code so i don't believe this
is that if you take a look
we're very different today than we were
a year ago even though we still have
problems but 90 of the schools are open
now was 98 is down to 90 but is open now
because we spent the time and the money
in the recovery act to provide for the
ability of schools to remain open
and you know what we're doing now is we
talked about
you know how we're dealing with uh with
testing well you know we have been doing
now we've had 300 million tests per
month so far
and uh that's 11 million tests a day in
addition to that we've we're in the
process of avoiding 500 000 new tests
and so
we're going to be able to control this
the new normal is not going to be what
it is now it's going to be better thank
you
[Music]
any response
president trump is legally and
criminally responsible for january
you